You're laying here. Coaches will coach it from here.
We're watching your feet, we're watching your hips, we're watching your past.
We're watching.
Is this a cut? No, it's not a cut.
Is it a cut? No, it's not a cut.
Those shoes are huge.
They're at the right time to let you down.
Alright, we're going to take you to a couple of form of roles.
Just get your cycle bag over here.
You guys on the sweep will have to get in line now.
Okay?
And I'll be over here to take you.
We'll use the whistle.
Ready?
Yep, yep, yep.
Hey, long lane.
Ready?
Yep.
Hey, long lane.
Don't run over.
Ready?
Get that ball in the hand, get it going.
All you got to do is get it and get it going.
Don't delay it.
So, come in and get the ball off.
Oh, after here.
Yeah, Ricky, need him in this one?
Those makes passes, they went away on the 70.
Shannon?
Here right here.
Really good.
80's ready.
No.
Get ready.
Nice, Brendan.
Yeah, what I'm saying is...